it's been almost a year since Red Dead
Redemption twos last trailer but now
rockstar has finally pulled back the
curtain a little more for their
follow-up to 2010's critically acclaimed
Western if you haven't seen the trailer
yet pause this video watch it and then
come back here if you haven't finished
Red Dead Redemption beware because there
will be spoilers alright let's get to it
this trailer opens up with a few shots
of a lush frontier and a man riding into
frame we find out shortly after that
this man is arthur morgan a wanted
fugitive a debt collector of sorts for a
gang and most likely the playable
character in the next scene we see a
woman warning in front of a grave and
morgan is talking to a young man morgan
says maybe when your mother's finished
moaning your father now keeper in black
on your bed this scene could be a number
of things but I think the woman is
Abigail Marston and the boys Jack
Marston it may sound like I'm pulling at
threads here but the boy looks like he
could be an older Jack Marston before
you step into his shoes at the end of
one this does complicate the timeline a
bit but we'll get to that later next we
see a quick shot of what's presumably
the van der Linde gang John Marsten's
old gang from the first preparing to
hold up a train this is followed by a
shot of Morgan saying they are wanted in
three different states judging by the
landscape we've seen in this trailer in
the first it seems obvious that Red Dead
Redemption 2 will take place further
north than the first probably a
representation of northern California
and Oregon if the map that leaked
earlier is to be trusted then it looks
like we will be able to revisit some
northern parts of Red Dead Redemption
world like the Great Plains and tall
trees as well as travel further north
the landscapes we've seen so far seemed
to support this next we are back at the
Train Robbery the most notable thing
about this shot is this silhouette back
here he looks a lot like Bill Williamson
who is one of the men John was hunting
throughout the first game
you implore me you always were one for
fancy words after some more shots of the
terrain we are back on Morgan and he
looks to be robbing a bank this is a
rockstar game after all so a bank
robbing scene would makes sense shortly
after we get a brief glimpse of a
character who offers to be an extra gun
for hire we don't know much about this
character but it kind of begs the
question will gta5 style heists being
read dead - given that you're an outlaw
it wouldn't surprise me however if it is
present I doubt it will be as prominent
as it is in GTA 5
here are some smaller things worth
pointing out in the next few shots there
are crocodiles we might be able to swim
which you couldn't do in the last game
and you can get a bow and arrow
the next key character we are introduced
to is this woman Bonnie McFarlane a key
ally in the first game comes to mind but
it's hard to say if that's her it could
be a younger or older Bonnie but I don't
think it sounds like her however shortly
after we get a shot of Morgan lasting a
horse in front of a ranch house while
this house doesn't quite match up with
the McFarlane ranch house it does have
some similarities if we do end up
revisiting the McFarlane ranch then I
have a feeling we will see Bonnie again
and finally we get a shot of Dutch the
antagonist and one who ultimately dies
this means that Red Dead Redemption 2
will in fact take place before one but
based on that boy in the widow we see
earlier I think this game will take
place both before during and after the
first the biggest issue with this theory
though is where was Morgan during Red
Dead Redemption 1 if he was part of the
gang why didn't Marston mention him
maybe he died before the events of one
unfortunately we won't know the answer
to these questions until Red Dead
Redemption 2 launches in spring 2018 I
am beyond hyped for this game and I've
probably already watched the trailer at
least a dozen times but I'm sure I've
missed a few things if you see anything
else drop it in the comments or hit me
up on twitter at jacob deck and if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to
subscribe it really helps us out thank
you